Okay, so we've got cyborgs coming, and we've
got robots and we've got genetically engineered
animals and we've got genetically engineered
plants...
WAIT A MINUTE I'VE GOT AN IDEA.
[[MUSIC PLAYING]]
Hey everybody, Trace here reporting for DNews!
BIONIC PLANTS.
BIONIC.
PLANTS.
They're a thing, and they're coming.
Plants clean and revitalize the air for us,
hold soil in place for other plants, protect
wildlife from predators and weather, produce
nutrition and SO MANY other things.
But scientists at MIT looked and plants and
were like, "We can do better."
Their experiments with plants involved embedding
nanomaterials -- materials so small you can't
see them with the naked eye.
These nanomaterials could add to plants' functions
and enhance their natural abilities..
// We totally need a Bionic Man joke...
These MIT researchers created a solution of
modified, negatively charged DNA wrapped nanotube
particles wrapped in polyacrylic acid.
They added some of the solution to the underside
of leaves so they could enter through the
leaf's natural pores, called stomata -- remember
that from high school bio class??
Once inside the leaves, this acid allows the
material to pass through the membrane into
the chloroplast to deliver the nano-payload!
It reminds me of the Terminator, a robot surrounded
by organic material... yikes.
Normally, a leaf can use about 10 percent
of the energy that hits the leaf, but with
the addition of these carbon nanotubes, the
leaf can pull in wavelengths normally out
of its reach, adding a 49-percent increase
in overall electron flow!
This is the most basic level of what they've
dubbed, "plant nanobiotics," so though the
scientists CAN make plants do this, they don't
actually know what that 49-percent increase
in electron flow will do to the plant in question.
But the possibilities are astounding, with
an increase in electron output we might see
plants that can detect contaminants in the
water, air or soil out in the yard or in a
forest...
You could end up with a fern that enhances
your Wi-Fi signal, or a tree that pulls in
over-the-air television.
Because it's so new, the possibilities are
endless!
Funnily enough, this technology got its start
when the researchers were attempting to create
plant-based solar cells... instead, we just
made plants better.
Who knows where a little science will take
you?
Think about it for a second, and tell us what
crazy plant nanobionics you'd want to create
if you could.
Share your ideas down in the comments and
subscribe for more DNews -- thanks for watching!